now here are you gonna start the
recording
yeah it's recording good okay excellent
all right uh hi everyone welcome to
the high dimensional seminar um
today we have adam clivens from ut
austin we're very fortunate to have him
speaking
about computational statistical gaps for
learning neural networks
so taking away adam okay thanks
uh salute thanks for having me thanks
for inviting me and
before i begin let me just plug this new
um at ut where the headquarters for this
new nsf ai institute
one of these ai institutes and the our
theme
we were uh we were given an award in the
foundations of machine learning track
so we're now the home for this
institute for foundations of machine
learning it's called ifml
and we're aggressively
recruiting postdocs um we're going to be
having a lot of you know foundational ml
programs some stuff will be joint with
simon's
upcoming simon's programs uh we'll be
recruiting
uh jointly fellows with simon's but if
you're interested in the postdoc
please apply you can just email me or
alex demarcus there are instructions and
if you
uh see there's a big there's a link
there postdoctoral positions are
available and
um you know we have a team of people
so i'm the director and alex demakus is
the co-director and
then we have a really amazing team of
researchers from
ut austin and uw and also microsoft
research
wichita state university so
if you are so you know
you can have the chance to work with all
of these people
so i encourage anybody who's interested
to apply
okay thanks for letting me do some
shameless promotion
um anyway yeah the the talk title is
computational statistical gaps for
learning neural networks
um can you hear me am i still
broadcasting okay
yeah we can hear you okay great
um so uh
what i'm really interested in where i'm
really coming from
is an algorithmic question so this line
of research
is really interested in the question of
uh
what are the most powerful algorithms
for learning neural networks
and it's a question that's you know
super important but i think
um is we may have lost track of a little
bit
um i think right now we sort of take for
granted that the current
best algorithm that we have for training
or learning neural networks
is back propagation or algorithms that
are based on gradient descent
and um the question that i've been
thinking about for the last several
years
is you know is that all there is i mean
gradient descent back propagation it's
an incredible algorithm it's a great
algorithm
it's had a lot of success but sometimes
we don't even
stop to think that you know there might
be
potentially a better algorithm for
training neural networks or
there might even be some say
pre-processing steps that we want to
perform
that you know you could use in
conjunction with back propagation or
gradient descent
and i think that these are super
important algorithmic questions
uh given the importance of you know deep
learning and training neural networks
and they're a little bit overlooked
right now in my opinion
so the analogy that i like to make for
this line of research
is basically an analogy to sort of the
simplex
method uh also you know an amazing
algorithm
used to solve linear programs all the
time but it took a long time before
i think most people would agree that
this smooth analysis paper of dan
spillman and shanghua tang
really gave some powerful compelling
you know provable guarantees or reasons
as to why the simplex method works well
in practice
it took a long it took decades for this
research to appear
and you know a complementary set of
algorithms to the simplex
method would be interior point methods
that was you know a major breakthrough
and optimization
algorithms gave the first you know
polynomial time
efficient algorithms for solving linear
programs
and i would argue that right now sort of
stochastic gradient descent
is like our modern day sort of simplex
method it works really well in practice
it's very simple it's a great algorithm
uh but it's you know it turns out to be
very difficult to analyze and we don't
quite understand why it works
and even worse we don't have really a
complementary set of algorithms for
gradient descent
the way we do for the simplex method and
so what i'm really interested in is
coming up with
not maybe the word alternative is a
strong word but at least
a set of algorithms that are perhaps
complementary to
uh gradient descent where you know we
can reason
about their runtime you know you can
give you know provable rigorous bounds
on things like convergence sample
complexity
okay so before i dive in and
you know explain the the algorithmic
problems that i'm that i'm looking at
let me just mention two models of
learning
uh many of you i'm sure have seen them
before
these are just you know if you've heard
of the student teacher model or pac
learning
so on and so forth these are all
basically the same the model is that i
receive these examples
x i and y i y i being the labels
drawn from some distribution d and i'm
going to assume that y
is actually equal to c of x for some
concept
c in script c and so you can think of
script c
as a class of neural networks
it's just a function class
and the goal here is going to be after
seeing you know you get to draw a bunch
of these examples and then you want to
output some
classifier h whose test loss so i'm not
really interested in
training loss per se i'm interested in
test loss uh
so you want to output hypothesis h whose
test loss
is small less than or equal to epsilon
and i i'm using square loss here
just for simplicity and i'm also i may
refer to this as sort of a regression
problem
because we're looking at square laws so
this is
one model of learning that i'll be
examining
so i'm calling that regression and then
there's also the classification problem
and in the classification problem your
labels y here
are always going to be boolean 0 1
and with the guarantee that the
conditional mean function is equal to c
of x
for some function c and script c so
you know y is a boolean label but the
expectation of y given x
is actually equal to uh c of x for some
say neural network and some class of
neural networks
script c and then again we want to
output a
hypothesis h classifier whose zero one
loss
instead of square loss we want zero one
loss to be small so we want the
probability when you draw a new example
that h of x does not equal y is less
than or equal to epsilon
and this is the p concept or
probabilistic concept model
due to kerns and shapiro
okay so uh so one one model is just
regression
the other model is classifications
and um just some other preliminaries so
i'm going to be looking at this problem
from you know arguably sort of the most
well studied
you know natural setup and that is
you know we'll start with script c being
a one layer
neural network and by that i mean
concretely it's equal to the sum
of uh k hidden units so you have these
lambda i's these are the weights
and then you have these w eyes these are
the hidden
the hidden weights uh the hidden units
and you know you have this sigma here
it's an activation you can think of
sigma
you know as being relu or tange or you
know whatever non-linear activation
you'd like but
i'm going to be thinking about relu
probably for most of the talk
um and so you know y is just going to be
equal to
you know your output here is just going
to be in the regression case is just
going to be equal to
uh this linear combination of non-linear
activations
and the other sort of assumption that
i'm going to assume is that the marginal
distribution on
x is uh gaussian
and and um so
you know sometimes i'll i i would say at
this point this setup is sort of
canonical
if you look at the literature on you
know learning neural networks over the
last say five years there are
probably you know dozens of papers
written on this particular
problem in this particular setup every
year
okay so it's a very natural test
yeah adam can i bug you with a question
um can you comment a little bit on why
why i know you say this is canonical but
maybe just commenting on the field then
why small test error is a reasonable
goal here
i thought that there's some notion that
the generalization performance of sgd in
practice is not necessarily well
explained or maybe it's controversial
whether it's well explained
by it achieving small text error
you know something about it finding uh
some kind of special
special sets of parameters that have
small test error and also happen to
generalize well
um so given that you're looking for
alternatives to sgd why is this the
right metric
i didn't totally understand your
question i mean it's the
it's it's the gold standard for metrics
you want small test error as opposed to
small
training error i mean it's trivia oh
sorry you said i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm
sorry i'm just uh
uh yeah good point sorry um i just got
confused about test test sets and
training sets
yeah i would have said generalization
yeah yeah you want small
generalization error people mean
different things when they say that so i
try to avoid that word
but i'm just pointing out that and i'll
talk about that in just a second but
um you know you want your model to
actually have predictive power
and so the way you would measure
predictive power is that would have
small test error not
yes yeah it's a small training error
yeah great but sorry i uh
no i literally thought you just no
training here
there's great and yet there's still a
lot of confusion about that and i'll
talk about that in just a minute
okay um so as i mentioned in the
abstract
uh this problem is information
theoretically easy
um you know pick your favorite measure
of complexity from neural networks it
could be something very classical like
vc dimension
you could use something slightly more
modern such as rademacher complexity
you could merely count parameters
pick your favorite measure of complexity
we know that the sample complexity
for learning one layer of neural
networks is polynomial
in every parameter that appears so d
the dimension k the number of hidden
units one over epsilon you know if you
want to add a
a parameter in there for probability of
success you can do that as well
we know that what we want is an
efficient run time
and i guess i want to emphasize that at
a minimum
we want our running time to be
polynomial or at least sub-exponential
in the ambient dimension
d and the reason for that is that as you
recall
i'm really interested in algorithms and
if you allow me to run in time
exponential in the dimension
then typically i can do some sort of
just brute force search
over all possible you know using a net
of potentially all possible
neural networks of a particular size and
you know the learning
problem from an algorithmic standpoint
sort of becomes trivial
so um of course you would like to be
polynomial in all the parameters but
um you know really um
the most important one to be
sub-exponential or polynomial is the
ambient dimension d
okay so let me just remind you that um
you know
what happens if p equals np um
well then it turns out that you know all
of these learning problems maybe it's
sort of easy to see that all of these
learning problems turn out to be easy
why is that well i can take a large
number of examples drawn from this
distribution still polynomial and all
the parameters
by large i mean say a large polynomial
and then what i can do
is uh use my my non-deterministic power
to
guess a one layer relu network of
smaller size
than the training set that i've chosen
that has low square loss
must exist one because we assume that
all the labels are coming from
are labeled exactly according to some
one layer neural network and so i can
just guess one
and then i can apply any of these
classical theorems of generalization
because i've
i have a one layer neural network that's
smaller
than the of size that's smaller than my
training set
and so you can apply any of these sort
of classical bounds and you can prove
just immediately that it will also have
small test error
okay so if p equals np you really are in
good shape and
i'm just highlighting that this is
inherently a computational problem
unfortunately as it turns out that you
know
um if you look at the literature in in
on you know training computationally in
computational learning theory on
training neural networks from say
you know the late 80s and onward most of
the results that we have regarding
you know finding these classifiers with
low air low test
error are negative uh so there's a
there's
there's a classic result of blom and
rivest i think in
from 88 or 89 that shows and a lot of
people cited it shows that
finding small networks with low training
hair is is np
hard and and the setup that they have in
their result
um really crucially uses the fact that
you have that you're working with
discrete distributions and discrete
labels so
the the non-linear activations are
threshold
so they're not uh continuous so they're
not relu or tange or something
and um
and the training sets themselves are are
are uh you know they're discreet
they have boolean features and i guess
you know
um if you if you look at the literature
on these types of hardness results
it just becomes very clear that
learning problems over discrete domains
can really encode
what are thought to be very
computationally hard problems such as
well such as np hard problems but also a
variety of cryptographic problems
um and the takeaway message is really if
you want to learn boolean functions
over discrete domains you know you're in
trouble i mean things are very
life is very hard and i think that some
people
sort of started to get a little
disillusioned um with some of these
results because
you know i think whatever what people
really wanted were positive results they
wanted new algorithms for
for learning you know rich function
classes
and instead the field sort of you know
proved
a very rich and in my opinion very
interesting set of hardness results
so some people were a little
disappointed
in the results that came out of this
kind of line of research
i'm i personally think that they're
terrific and i'll explain
why why i feel that way later i think
these hardest results are super valuable
and continue to be super valuable um but
but i think that some people
were a little disappointed by them um
especially when sort of you look at the
resurgence of
deep learning and deep learning theory
uh you know
given the performance and practice i
think some people began to look back at
these
at these results and sort of said well
you know they're nice but they don't
really
they're not really meaningful with
respect to what's going on quote unquote
in practice
so that brings me to a result
um that i want to tell you about with my
students
serbia goal arvind golokata jihan jin
sushu
and sushir karmakar this was an ic melon
20 just recently in 2020 and
the title is just super polynomial lower
bounds for learning one layer neural
networks using gradient descent
and what we show here is that um
really learning even one-layer neural
networks even when the marginal
distribution is gaussian
is still a very hard problem
it's not necessarily just because you're
working over a boolean domain or that
you're encoding sort of
discrete uh np-hard combinatorial
optimization problems or even
cryptography
so what we show is unconditionally
if you would like to learn a one layer
neural network
even if the marginal distribution is
gaussian and you're going to run
gradient descent
then we can prove unconditionally that
you cannot achieve
a polynomial in the dimension run time
uh to obtain small test error it's just
not possible and in particular
this rules out um several common
approaches that people have been looking
at for learning neural networks
such as you know using ntk or the neural
tangent kernel
or looking at a mean field approach a
sort of particle-based approach
for coming up with neural networks it
rules out over parameterization so
you know common common technique or
common technique that's studied right
now
you know is you over parameterize you
form a very
you're trying to learn a small network
you form a very large network
you run gradient descent on it and you
you hope for the best
and and our results show that you know
in the worst case or
although you know even even when the
distribution is gaussian even
in the simplest case these approaches
are just going to fail adam a quick
question does the initialization
matter here please no no
one more question adam um so so i mean
uh
what exactly so are you also ruling out
like what is it exactly that you're
ruling out is it the case that if you
have um
you know exponentially many gates in
your first layer
gradient descent can still possibly do
it or maybe you'll get up to this in the
future slides
yeah yeah i'll i'll be more concrete in
just a second
um but um
i mean yes if if you're willing to
[Music]
so it actually rules out you know any i
mean just looking ahead it's going to
rule out any
you know correlational sq algorithm that
uses a polynomial number of queries so
you know if you want to so even if you
use an exponential size
network but you're only you know you're
only training it for a polynomial number
of steps you're still not going to
succeed
excellent thanks
okay so just to elaborate a little bit
on this um you know ruling out these
other over parameterized approaches
um sometimes i get asked the question
well i thought that you know if you use
ntk it solves this problem
and going back to sam's question no it
doesn't basically
um the upshot of you know you know a lot
of research on on the neural tangent
kernel
is that if you run gradient descent
on an over parameterized network then
this
over parameterized network will quickly
achieve small training error
which is which is interesting but if you
want to prove that this
network actually has low test error then
you need to prove some sort of
generalization bound
and in order to do that you need to take
more assumptions and typically
the assumptions that are taken are that
your over parameterized network
has small model complexity
in some in with respect to some measure
of model complexity
and once you do that then you can sort
of immediately apply one of these
classical generalization bounds because
we know that if
if the classifier that you happen to get
is of low complexity then it will
generalize and so
if you if you look carefully at some of
these assumptions they basically just
sort of immediately imply that your
uh that your model has low complexity so
yes of course
then it will generalize but but these
require you know
an assumption so and these assumptions
are essentially of the form well yes it
generalizes
okay so we're going to prove two types
of statistical query lower bounds for
this problem
um and i i need to make this distinction
for reasons you'll see in a second but
uh you know there's this csq model
uh and and the sq model the sq model is
more general the csq model is more
restrictive in the csq model c
stands for correlational statistical
query the learner
in this particular model the learner so
instead of getting to see
examples drawn from the distribution
instead what happens is the learner
picks a query function
phi and receives the expectation of 5x
times y label to within some tolerance
parameter tau
and then in the more general sq model
the learner picks
five x comma y and receives you know
expectation
with respect to this the distribution of
five x comma y to within some tolerance
parameter tau
and the nice thing about the csq model
is that
you know gradient descent
you can show pretty easily that gradient
descent
um is a csq algorithm
okay if you if you want to get an
estimate of your gradient
uh you know you just differentiate
you'll see that
that you can just plug in uh the
gradient for fi
the appropriate function for 5x there
and if you look at expectation of 5xy
you'll get an estimate of the gradient
to within
you know some value tau
okay so let me show you the actual
construction itself
for the lower bound and it turns out
that if you want to prove
a csq lower bound then it suffices to
find
a family of one layer here we're talking
about relu
um so so let me let me focus on relu for
just a second but it suffices to find a
family of
one layer relu networks that are almost
pairwise orthogonal that is to say you
want to come up with a family of
functions
you know capital f such that if you look
at any
f1 and f2 in capital f the expectation
uh with respect to x drawn from your
distribution of f1
times f2 is very small
okay and i just want to point out so so
that's really what you need to find
to prove one of these csq lower bounds
and
for discrete distributions so if you
allow me to use discrete distributions
like
the uniform distribution over the
hypercube
then it's pretty easy uh to come up with
this family of functions just using
parity functions so we know that parity
on different subsets of
input bits um parity functions are
pairwise
or exactly orthogonal and it's also not
too hard to see that
for uh with respect to a discrete
distribution
a one layer rayleigh network can compute
parity
okay and so um you'll immediately get
these super polynomial lower bounds
by taking parity on different subsets of
input bits
and then finding the corresponding
one-layer relu network that exactly
computes this parity function
so it's it's very straightforward if
you're allowed to use a discrete domain
and what was more difficult uh what is
more difficult for
for our situation is that the marginal
distribution is gaussian
and and so you know there's no sort of
parity function that we can that we can
try and compute
okay so here's the construction um
remember d is our dimension and so
you're going to fix some subset s
of d of size k and then i just have two
functions i need to define so
g sub s is the sum over
all w strings of length uh k
and this chi here of w is the parity
of w times phi
which is i think think of this as rel u
of w
inner product x um that the bits
uh uh according you know the the bits of
x indexed by s
and you have to divide by root k um
so right you might be thinking oh wait
you know g of s of x you're using the
parity function well
this is just a coefficient this chi of w
is just plus one or minus one
depending on what the parity of w is g g
s of x is not computing parity
um phi here is say rel u and so you're
looking at w inner product
x indexed by s and then you're taking
the sum over
all of these you're kind of summing up
over all these different plus
minus 1 coefficients
and then finally i'm going to define
this function f
which is some function odd function psi
of g
of s of x okay so you're just going to
run gs of x through
psi for any odd psi and in particular
psi could be the identity function so
you know i could just out i could just
use gs of x if i wanted
just two things to note so the size of
our family
is roughly d to the k as you enumerate
over all subsets of d
of size k and then each network
so g sub s has 2 to the k
terms that's because i'm summing over
all w and minus 1 1 to the k so it has 2
to the k terms
and here you can see that i can choose k
to be roughly log d
and i will get a family that has super
polynomial size
and so will require super polynomial
number of
uh statistical queries um
but each network actually only has two
to the k terms and so
each network will be of polynomial size
in the dimension
okay so that's the that's the
construction any questions on the
construction
this is the family and this works for
any activation not just value it works
for any
non-linear activation
okay so oh right so i'm going to prove
this so just to show you how simple this
is
i'm going to prove to you that these
families are orthogonal
and we'll use this this little fact that
i have in this orange box
which says that if you if you look at f
of s of x
and then you entry wise multiply it by z
you get the parity of z times f s of x
so you can just pull out the parity of z
you know this is a simple fact z is
z is a assign i mean z is signs right i
guess yeah
z z is pl yeah right thank you z is plus
minus one
uh it has plus minus one entries right
okay so i wanna show you that i want to
show you that for any two different
subsets or
s and t the the functions are in fact
orthogonal so i want to prove
that expectation of x
f x x times f t of x
is equal to zero and equivalently
i can pick i can just look at
first picking some z that has plus minus
one entries
and then looking at x
i can do this because of the sign
symmetry of the gaussian so this is the
only place where i'm using the fact that
the distribution is
gaussian in fact this
property holds for any sine symmetric
distribution and then i can use the fact
and pull out my z's
i'm sorry
and then here i have this these two
parity functions
and as we mentioned you know any two
distinct parity functions we said
s does not equal t uh is going to be
zero
and so that's just going to cancel
everything out and you're left with
zero so they're perfectly orthogonal
okay good simple
okay so it turns out that the the tricky
part of the proof
is to show that the family of functions
is non-zero so that you you're not just
that you know you're not just redefine
like all these functions aren't just
exactly the zero function
[Music]
and it's a little tricky um but it can
be done by looking at the appropriate
hermet expansion and
what we do in the paper for other
reasons is we actually quantitatively
show how far away these functions are
from the zero function
and admittedly to do that we need to use
one theorem from complex analysis
but once you have that you're done so
this will give you the csq lower bounds
and it will give you a quasi-polynomial
lower bound
uh quasi-polynomial size function family
that translates directly into a
quasi-polynomial
um csq lower amount
okay so as it turns out
csq algorithms are not the same as sq
algorithms
for real valued functions
it's easy to see for example that
it's easy to see for example that if you
want to learn her meat polynomials
they so take take the family of all her
meat polynomials
they're all pairwise exactly orthogonal
uh so
you know you can't you can't learn them
using a csq algorithm
but there is an uh a result due to
andoni at all
that does learn uh the hermit
polynomials
in time roughly two to the d instead of
um sorry
i should say like two to the k where k
is the degree
of the polynomials as opposed to d to
the k
which is what you would expect for any
which is what you would conclude for any
csq algorithm
but we can still obtain the the general
sq lower bounds for classification
if you want the full sq lower bounds we
can do that
and the the way we do that is we look at
the the associated classification
problem so
you know previously we were obtaining
these csq
lower bounds you know for this
regression problem if you move to the
harder case where you want to do
classification
you can show that you'll get the full sq
lower bounds so
if you take a one-layer neural network
and then run it through a soft max
you can show that there's no sql general
sq algorithm
for obtaining small test error in
polynomial time
oh yeah good and so so let me just
mention some prior work along these
lines there was a paper by song venpala
wilms and g that gave some type of
sq lower bound for learning one layer
neural networks
but it it required it held only for
small tolerance queries so in particular
it only held for gradient descent on
small batch sizes
and it also required very sharp
activations
and then there is some uh independent
work um
by diaco nicholas kane cantonese and
zerifus
that gave us um an exponential csq lower
bound we got a quasi-polynomial
uh csq lower bound for the for the case
of gaussians
they actually get an exponential csq
lower bound
um using a more sophisticated uh
construction
so our two constructions are actually
the same in two dimensions and then they
use a more sophisticated lifting from
two dimensions in order to get an
exponential
lower bound
is there exponential lower bound for any
activation or for particular activation
it's for any non-polynomial activation
so in particular
so if you have an uh if you want to
learn a network of size k
then it's for any activation
that has a non-zero hermit coefficient
above level k yes
okay so
yeah in particular if it's the
non-linear activation then you have
infinitely many and so everything is
fine
well if it's non-polynomial i should say
and um we also so we also actually did
some experiments
just to sanity check what was going on
and so
now these experiments are really simple
let me explain them
so the red line here is training loss so
what we did was
we took this function family and we
generated
a training set and then we trained we we
generated
an over parameterized neural network and
ran gradient descent on it
and you can see as you would expect from
the you know
the literature the training loss in red
here
you know pretty quickly goes to zero
whether you're doing classification or
regression
but the test loss which is the blue
dashed line
it just stays very high the whole time i
mean
it's just grainy descent even on an over
parameterized network is just failing to
achieve small test laws
and this green line here is on the
left-hand diagram that's the bayes
optimal classifier
so you really should be able to you
would hope that you you could achieve
like zero one loss uh close to the green
line
but instead when you run gradient
descent on an over-parameterized network
you're just you're just your test loss
is just very close to one half
okay um so just to summarize
let me see much time okay there's no csq
algorithm that can learn one layer of
neural networks in polynomial time
on the other hand as i mentioned there
are there are all these papers
out there um that are written on
learning one layer neural networks so
what's in these papers and you know
they're very interesting papers
uh you know um
it's it's there's there's a lot of
really good work i don't mean to you
know diminish that
um but these results typically require
assumptions
in order to obtain uh obtain small test
loss let me mention
um roughly how they work and what sort
of assumptions they need
so there's a rece this recent paper that
i mentioned by diaconicallus cane
contonus and zerifus
um well all of these works are sort of
tensor methods
so that's primarily been sort of the
only tool we have
for learning one layer neural networks
with respect to gaussians
and what they do um in this dkkz paper
is they look at this matrix
it's the expectation of y times x x
transpose minus identity and then they
they run pca
and what they prove is that the
the relevant directions of your hidden
units just sort of pop out once you do
that
and then you can run brute force search
in the relevant subspace
but this only works if the coefficients
those lambdas in your one layer neural
network are positive
and they don't it also you know all of
these results only hold for one layer of
neural networks
what's nice about this dkz result is
that it doesn't require anything else
about
any other assumptions on on the hidden
weight vectors but does require the
lambdas to be positive
and then there's a there have been many
papers that have explored sort of
tensor decomposition algorithms in the
context of learning one layer neural
networks this started with a paper
due to jasmine sejji and anan kumar
and for certain activations like tange
you can look at this third order tensor
expectation of y
x tensor three and
um you can do some tensor decomposition
uh decomposition and again
you will find you you will actually find
the hidden weight vectors you will do
parameter recovery
what assumptions do they need in order
to get this to work well
they require positive like dkkz they
require
positive coefficients on the lambda eyes
and they also require that these w's the
hidden weight vectors are well
conditioned or
just maybe an easier way to think about
it is the wi's the hidden weight vectors
have to be almost
orthogonal for their techniques to work
and also as you can see all of these
techniques
are csq they're just looking at
expectation of y times something and so
th
there's uh there's really no hope that
these types of
algorithms or analyses can be adapted to
learn
general one layer neural networks and i
should also say that these
these techniques also only seem to hold
for one layer
they critically use the fact that the
the underlying neural network is
is uh can be written as a one layer
neural network
adam can ask another question like what
if the activation is odd can't you just
assume the coefficient is
positive in the last layer what what
exactly happened in this case so the
lower bound still applies but
um
i guess i'm okay i i guess you i see so
for relu you cannot do that yeah
but like it was tanged then you could uh
assume it's positive
yeah but then um i i see and so
right i guess you're saying
that's true for tants you could do that
um
you still need the sort of conditioning
assumption i guess for the weight
vectors
sorry what was your is was that your
question or yeah yeah that was the
question
yeah oh okay yeah for odd activations um
i
for one layer it's okay to assume
they're positive yeah
okay so um i guess the point is that
without
you know taking further assumptions all
these approaches still require
exponential time in the dimension
even for learning one layer if you're
looking at say relu
activation and um
you know a really natural question is
are these assumptions necessary you know
can we do something smarter than brute
force search just to learn
you know one layer of neural networks
and so let me briefly tell how much time
do i have left so
or 10 minutes or
um you can so you have 10 minutes
officially but
you know if we go okay i know that's not
a disaster yeah it should
should be okay so let me so what i
wanted to talk about um
is our main positive result and this is
joint work with seton chen and raghu
mecca
uh this is a paper that we just put on
the archive
learning deep reality networks is fixed
parameter tractable
and i want to show you that you you can
do something that's not csq and you
actually can do something
that doesn't require any of these
assumptions and you can actually sort of
break this
one hidden layer barrier and do
something for general
uh deep value networks
um so you know how do i define
you know a higher depth value network so
so well i start with this inner
inner activation and then you you
multiply by
uh these weight matrices and then you
compose
so you know this is sort of the the
functional form of what a deep
value network will look like and our
main result is that
given examples xy
labeled according to one of these deep
relu networks
you can find a classifier g that has
small
test error um in in and the running time
is a
fixed polynomial in the ambient
dimension d
times some exponential function of only
the network's parameters
okay so that's that's our main result
and we don't need any assumptions on
like positivity of coefficients um
or you know the condition number of any
of these
weight matrices
what which uh which parameter i mean
maybe you can say
yeah so so they're a bunch so let me i
have it in
like in two slides
but so before i like concretely tell you
what the main result is
i just want to point out that it's the
first positive result of any sort that
i'm aware of for
learning value networks of or any neural
networks of depth more than two
and even when the parameters are all
constants and i'll tell you what the
parameters are in just a second
there's no sub-exponential in the
ambient dimension algorithm known
and it also gives the first example of
neural networks that can be efficiently
learned
you know via some polynomial time
algorithm but provably cannot be
learned in polynomial time using
gradient descent
okay so here are the parameters that you
wanted to see so
i i'm denoting depth is l
the lipschitz value of the network when
viewed as a function is lambda
the size is s that's the number of
activations
the rank of the hidden units in the
first layer
is k so you can just think of the number
of hidden units in the first layer being
k
and capital b is a bound on the spectral
norm
of all the weight matrices involved in
the network
okay and it turns out that we have to
you have to depend
somehow on this this lip shits parameter
is inherent i'll talk more about that in
just a second
okay and so the number of samples that
we require to obtain small test error
is roughly linear in d and then
a singly exponential function in k
s lambda 1 over epsilon that's your
accuracy parameter
and then times b raised to the power lk
and the running time is roughly
quadratic
times again this exponential times b to
the lk
squared i don't think it's so important
you know this
s versus a square i guess the main point
is that it's
you know it's a small polynomial and d
the ambient dimension
and then some singly exponential
function in the remaining parameters
so so did these parameters make sense or
yeah it's good okay
[Music]
okay so um our algorithm it's related to
a lot of different problems but
you can think the way you know we're
thinking of a rally network is that it's
a multi-index model
and by that i mean it's just some
function if you think about it
if w1 through wk are the hidden weight
vectors in the first layer
then the output of the entire rally
network no matter how deep it is
it's just some function of these values
okay many compositions are involved but
it is some function of these values
and the key thing that we would like to
understand
is how to find the subspace spanned by
w1 through wk
and because it's a function of just you
know the inner products of these
weight of these weight vectors in the
first layer with x
once you've found the subspace spanned
by these wwi's
you can try and attempt to do brute
force search in that particular subspace
and this problem is related to the
hunter learning problem
which as you know is defined or to learn
some function that depends on only k
relevant variables you know in in time
some fixed polynomial in the dimension
times f of k
it's it's also it's also related to a
problem called non-gaussian component
analysis
um sliced inverse regression
and in particular there's a paper by uh
my co-authors
chan and mecca that was in cult 2020
that um gave a result when f
is equal to a polynomial like f is you
know z squared or something or z cubed
they you know gave a non-trivial
algorithm for a multi-index model when f
was a polynomial now here uh f is
much different than a polynomial it's a
you know it's a relu network
and so the techniques from chen mecca 20
don't apply
um in fact the techniques that we have
in our paper are totally different
well are significantly different i
should say
um but but definitely their paper
uh you know you know inspired this work
okay so let me try and explain the
algorithm
uh briefly and then um in one of the
upcoming workshops we have in december
the one that i'm organizing uh satan is
actually going to give
a whole talk on this and you can get
more details from him
but remember that y is just so i have
this pi
here pi sub v that's the projection onto
the relevant subspace
and why because it only depends on say
the k hidden units in the first layer
is some function f of pi v of x
projected onto that relevant subspace
and then we're going to form this matrix
m sub tau
and it's the expectation of x y of the
indicator function that the absolute
value of y
is greater than tau times x x transpose
minus the identity
okay so you're basically you know if
your y
value is small this is just going to be
zero and once your y value is larger
than tau
well then you're going to start kind of
looking you're going to start taking
averages of
you know covariance matrices
it's easy to see that the vectors that
are orthogonal to your relevant subspace
are going to be in the kernel of m tau
and what we're hoping for what you'd
love to show
is that the top k singular vectors of m
tau
just span your relevant subspace so you
can form this matrix
empirically you know look at do do an
svd on this matrix and you're just
hoping
that the top k singular vectors span v
unfortunately we don't know how to prove
that
um you know
but but what you can prove is is that
you will find one direction okay and so
so here again
you know now i'm taking this matrix m
tau if you look at the orange box
and i'm looking at the inner product the
matrix pro inner product with pi
v and it's not it's easy to see that
this
is equal to the expectation again of
this indicator y is greater than tau
times the norm of pi v of x squared
minus k
so what you're hoping for is that you
can choose tau
to be large enough so that when the
value of your network is greater than
tau
the norm of x projected into the space
the relevant subspace v squared is at
least 2k
so this would become you know at least
2k
if that happens then when you look at
this inner product
you'll get something like k that's
because you qk minus k
times the probability that y is greater
than tau
okay and so first we need to kind of
show some anti-concentration of our
network which isn't
too bad and then you'll use some
lipschitz property
to kind of show that like a k will pop
out here
okay so those are two things that we
need to do
okay so um as i mentioned you know
you're hoping that like all of the
relevant directions will show up when
you do
when you do the singular value
decomposition but instead only
we could only prove is that one shows up
and so the question becomes well how do
you proceed
so it's not too hard to show that you'll
get one relevant direction and then
the question is well how do i get more
relevant directions
um so there are two cases well
you know let's assume we've recovered
some subspace w
of the relevant directions and we want
to we want to move on so this is kind of
the next step in our algorithm so we
have some subspace w
maybe w only contains one direction and
we want to make it w bigger we want to
get closer to
the relevant subspace well case one f of
x
minus f projected on to w is actually
small
well then we're done we basically
recovered the whole relevant subspace
case two so if this doesn't happen what
we're going to do is look at this
indicator function of y
min we're going to subtract off f of pi
w of x
we're just going to take the label y and
sort of subtract off what we've already
figured out
um and then again we'll we'll multiply
it by this xx transpose minus identity
that's going to be our strategy
the big problem is that we don't know f
um you know that's what we're trying to
learn
so if i want to form an empirical
estimate of this expectation of y minus
f of pi w of x i mean i'm in trouble i
don't know what f
is you know i know what w is i can
project x onto w but then what is f of
pi of w of x
so what did we do well uh we we actually
try
all functions f and so we needed to
prove
that first you know if you knew as you
enumerate over all functions f
in the subspace you'll still find a new
direction
and we need to prove soundness i.e you
won't find any false
direction so you won't find any kind of
spurious directions
and uh you know there are many
complications
first is that we don't actually have
like the true subspace
w we only have sort of an approximation
to w and also as we're enumerating over
all possible functions in the subspace
we're only getting approximations to f
we're not getting the true f
so every time we want to form a new find
a new direction in this relevant
subspace we actually have to enumerate
over all possible
relu networks which turned out to be
non-trivial in and of itself
um and so the key structural fact like
why are we why did we have to
you know where are we using the fact
that this is a relu network we're using
it in several places but one of the key
structural facts
is this very interesting
characterization from i guess what you
would
what people would call tropical geometry
and that is if you have
f which is some high dimensional
continuous piecewise linear function
that has capital m pieces
then they're all ex then there exists
some subset little
m of this index set m such that f
x can always be written in this max min
representation
it's the max over all j and little m of
the min of little i
and i sub j of gi of x
okay so it turns out for any continuous
piecewise linear function and we know
that
you know relu networks are continuous
piecewise linear functions
that we can write them in this way and
so in order to kind of brute force
search
this this gives us something that we can
use in order to
both one brute force search over value
networks because we can kind of look at
this representation and brute force
using this representation
and two it gives us a quantitative way
to bound how close our approximations
actually are
so just as an example um
you know if f of x were a one layer
value network which is i've written here
so this is one layer
and you you look at these sets capital p
is the set of all i such that lambda i
is greater than zero
and capital n is the set of all i such
that lambda i is less than or equal to
zero
well then you can just write f of x as
the max
over all subsets of p the min of over
all t subsets of n of w s minus w t
inner product x and the reason for that
is that kind of
your the max player is trying to take
all the lambda i's
that your input x makes positive uh
you know and and your min player is
trying to
again take all of the lambda i's that x
also makes nonzero
and so you you add up all the ws for the
positive coefficients and you subtract
off
all the wt's for the negative
coefficients and that's why
this representation gives you the exact
output for the rayleigh network
okay i'm going to wrap up here so just
to recap we found one direction
we used filtered pca on the differences
and we enumerated over all
possible value networks and i guess one
important thing to point out is this
filtered pca approach
see when we're forming this matrix uh
notice that we have this indicator
function here and that is not a csq
type query because it's we're not just
multiplying this covariance matrix by y
we're actually multiplying by the
indicator that y
is larger than something so that's why
it's not a csq algorithm that's why it
escapes
the lower bounds that i mentioned at the
beginning of the talk so what's open
well
still fully polynomial time for one
layer
you know as we showed or as we discussed
you don't need these these positivity
assumptions for relu networks
you don't need uh
these well conditioning assumptions can
you do it i i don't know how to do it
um you know all of our our analyses
for these higher depth networks are
exponential in the parameters can you
improve any of can you get
can you become sub exponential in any of
them that would be very interesting
and also crucial to our upper bound or
positive result is that we used value
i don't know how to get this to work for
say tanch
it really critically uses uh relu
um in several ways so it would be
interesting too
to improv to to improve that okay i'll
stop here
thanks
okay uh thanks adam i guess everyone uh
you know wave your hands in the air is
applause
uh so uh yeah i guess uh if if there are
any questions
uh feel free to ask so maybe i can ask a
question while other people are thinking
of their questions
um so okay but so the algorithm that you
gave is an sq algorithm uh it's just not
it is it is an sq algorithm it is not a
csq algorithm
right cool all right that was my
question
well as a follow-up i i think you said
this but just to sort it out again
how does that square with the lower
bounds the lower bounds only apply to
csq but you said that some other lower
bounds
like the lower construction you did in
detail is csq but you also have sq lower
bounds
yeah so um that's correct so
it's the csq lower bounds our algorithm
is not csq so it's not subject to the
csq lower bounds
yeah the sq lower bounds were for
classification
we're not solving the classification
problem
it's a it's a regression problem great
thanks
so maybe you can ask a question um sure
you have this brute force step in the
algorithm which
might make you not want to sort of
implement it in practice is there some
sort of uh
version that you can't prove works but
but might work that
uh you know i guess we'll turn this
result into no no this is a good
question i mean
and i think this is what's really
exciting about this
line of kind of investigating algorithms
for learning neural networks because
any small improvement that you make has
really radical implications i mean has
not i wouldn't say radical implications
but has huge impact
um you know because you're training your
own networks so
you know you can view the sort of
filtered pca as a pre-processing step
and one thing you could implement
is just you know run filtered pca and
then run sgd
and that's something that we're working
on implementing right now
um so as i you know just just even
having a pre-processing step that
that that improves things
would be a game changer
okay well thanks everybody don't forget
to apply for the ifml
positions if you're interested all right
thanks adam for the great talk
see you next week okay bye